[Music]
his hearing tomorrow is set to be
carried live by several networks and
like many of you someone who will be
watching closely as former OJ trial
juror Lionel Cryer now you may remember
he is the man who raised his fist in
solidarity with Simpson as he left the
courtroom at the OJ trial well he has a
very different sentiment today
from the point that I received that
notice everything about my life changed
if it doesn't fit you must equipment
that's former OJ juror Lionel Cryer in
FX's the People vs OJ Simpson he's
depicted as giving OJ erased this salute
as he left the courtroom after the
verdict that moment really did happen
but a lots changed since then
my personal feeling is that mr. Simpson
probably did commit these crimes the
thing about it is is he to me he was a
very clever criminal crier says he voted
to acquit because prosecutors bungled
the case his feelings changed when okay
wrote this controversial book if I did
it well the book actually was the
turning point for me to go to the
feeling that he probably did kill those
people
because I thought that that was such a
bush-league thing for him to do at that
time and then I'm thinking what would
your kids think about you doing
something like that
in 2008 Simpson was convicted in Nevada
of armed robbery I didn't want to steal
anything from anybody I don't think
anybody that's it I wanted anybody
else's stuff just my own I'm a firm
believer in karma and you get what you
saw I believe and so and it's really
weird because to me it's almost like it
was godlike that things happen the way
they did in Nevada and he wound up going
to jail and having to have to do some
time for something crier is part of a
four night special on oxygen the jury
speaks a true-crime series that looks at
high-profile trials like Michael Jackson
Robert Blake and OJ Simpson the series
dramatizes how the stress of the trial
led to Cryer suffering a heart attack he
was released after a night in the
hospital and was sent immediately to
judge ito's chambers I thought it
letting judge Ito know look man I'm sick
I can't take this anymore
Johnnie Cochran jumped up immediately
ah doesn't he like football and they
were gonna take us and let us go to
football games as a means to try to
appease me as for Simpsons parole
hearing tomorrow Cryer expects you'll
win the only thing I would hope for is
that he would come out and try to make
his life purposeful worthy as far as for
understanding that hey look you've been
given a gift here if you did kill these
people and you got away with it by all
means you need to think about how you
can do things to change your life and
try to make his life better I don't know
what Oh Jay will do if he gets out but I
will tell you this we will be there
tomorrow for the hearing Michelle Turner
will have every single detail from
Lovelock Nevada gonna be interesting
right it is
[Music]
you